President Biden feeling the heat over
his Advanced stage left-wing magazine
the Atlantic hitting Joe with a brutal
headline step aside Joe Biden the
president has no business running for
office at age 80. and about half of
Americans agree with that idea a
majority says that the best Stage for a
president is in their 50s but all of
that is a joke to the big guy who keeps
making quips like these
a lot of you are tired
they're tired now I I get it
I try being 110 and doing it again
I know I'm 198 years old
but all kidding aside
think about that call me old
I call it being seasoned
and if Biden takes that advice and Bows
out here's another reminder that his
number two is far worse Kamala Harris
taking people on a verbal roller coaster
while trying to define the word culture
culture is
it it is a reflection of our moment and
our time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and
and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because
every you know
it comes in the morning
[Laughter]
it comes in the morning oh oh boy all
right 40 49 of Voters have a negative uh
view of Kamala I think she said a
negative 17 or something crazy like that
are we sure Kamala is not the one that
dropped the coke bag yeah gee yeah The
West Wing Lobby is right below
the vice president I think she gets a
bum rap I honestly do I think she's in a
horrible situation why is that have you
seen the president would you I would
literally distance myself from I think
she's
not only distance herself but I don't
think there's any respect coming from
the Biden side either yeah I feel like
they set her up to fail constantly
trying to set her up to be the Fall Guy
the problem is he falls so many
different directions she can't possibly
cover all of it and here's another thing
about Biden he's hurting because it's
not about being 80 years old has nothing
to do with that Harrison Ford is 81 and
still doing the damn thing but no one's
going to see his movie because the other
80 year old who's working is terrible so
Joe Biden's even hurting 81 year olds
who got their stuff together because his
aging process is so far more severe it's
not about the number it's about his
behavior the sporadic things shaking
hands with dead people wandering off
those are all the unfortunate signs of
getting old has nothing to do with some
80s are are sprying got it going on or
calling dead people you know to stand up
that's not fair though because it used
to be cool to talk to dead people
remember that movie about the dead
people probably like damn that's cool
now you want to judge him because he can
do it it's not fair all right give
Kamala a chance yeah I think she's had
her chance uh but in the meantime
but Jessica I'll go to you in the
meantime you've got Gavin Newsom there
Gavin Newsom is running around he's
doing he's uh being a surrogate for Joe
Biden but uh do you think that he's a
bigger threat uh to Joe Biden than
Donald Trump
no I I don't think that anyone in the
Democratic party right now is a threat
to him everyone is coalescing behind him
AOC just endorsed him which was a very
big deal so she's the the head of the
left wing of the progressive side of the
party and she came out early and said
Joe Biden is the guy there's such an
incredible track record of achievements
to go into this election and I think
she's really sending a signal to other
people in the squad people on the left
who might prefer for Bernie Sanders who
has also already endorsed him or an
Elizabeth Warren who's serving as a
surrogate for him to say we're standing
behind Joe if for some reason Joe Biden
decides of his own volition that he's
not going to run sure Gretchen Whitmer
Gavin knew some they're all getting in
and they should I think they'd make
fantastic candidates the age thing is a
real consideration and I thought that
what Hillary Clinton was saying in that
conference that you went to a few weeks
ago was really butchered because she was
I think being honest and reflecting what
people feel which is that you should be
able to talk about these things you have
to acknowledge and not just make a joke
about it to say this is why I'm fit to
do the job this is why I've done a good
job and deserve to be re-elected but
when you see the contrast and I should
note that Elliott Cohen who wrote that
piece in the Atlantic is a republican
who worked under Condoleezza Rice in the
Bush Administration at the state
department he was a supporter of Joe
Biden's over Donald Trump's but this
isn't like a died in the wool liberal
this is Elliot Cohen but you have that
juxtaposed to the fact that Joe Biden is
out there today we got this jobs report
we have the longest streak of
unemployment under four percent in
American history and people are talking
about how oh they're not good jobs or
it's you know people not in prime age
the prime age employment is 81 that's
the highest since April of 2001. that's
extraordinary and tell me why people
don't feel that way it doesn't have
something to do with their wages I yeah
it probably does because when inflation
is outpacing the wage growth and prices
are going at a rate that your wage even
if it's increasing you can't keep up
with that pull after poll after poll
shows people it's not showing up in
their real life yet and so they don't
believe they know things are moving in
the right direction but it's not showing
up in their paychecks when they're still
paying too much for groceries and rent
and gas and all of those things it's
really tough um and I think that adds to
The Angst about more time with President
Biden for those who are opposed to him
it's interesting though in the polling
on the age when you ask the same people
about Trump who is not that far off from
age from President Biden they have a lot
less worry and concern about the age
issue with Trump like you said I don't
think it's just a number it's probably
the energy and that kind of thing I will
say that okay they say best age for our
president is in 50s which means ladies
we can't do it because after 50 we're
out of our Prime so there's an option
for us there I heard that somewhere but
this is what I like about covering
Washington because I'm considered young
there when you're covering the settings
and the Supreme Court and you know
average those ages out it's like 103. um
I'm a spring chicken there so we can
talk about age all we want yes I love it
you're south of 80 in DC and you're
youngster all right Charlie but why why
does Biden not embrace it you know why
does he not say instead of making a joke
about it and I think that's the point of
the piece in the Atlantic irrespective
of who wrote at the Atlantic published
it right well I think that uh he can't
he doesn't really joke unless the joke
is written for him and when he tries to
joke uh with a joke that's not written
for him it usually Falls flat there is
no doubt as Jessica pointed out that Joe
Biden is Santa Claus to the left that we
have never had a more left-wing
president uh in the white house he has
given them everything that they've ever
wanted Kamala Harris started out as the
insurance policy against the 25th
Amendment when Joe Biden started losing
his mind the problem is she has now
become the greater threat if they could
embalm Joe Biden and keep him around
forever they would because he's
delivering to the far left and that what
their great fear is that something is
going to happen to him and then it's
going to automatically go to Kamala
Harris if they could figure out a way to
blast him out of there and then throw it
open to a primary and get a Gretchen
Whitmer or a Gavin Newsom into the mix I
think they would be a lot more open to
the idea but as it is now they they just
have to keep Joe Biden propped up and
Kamala Harris out in her office above
the West Wing Lobby where they found the
cocaine Mayo found it was several
suggestions
B Block the vice president
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else